madame mademoiselle monsieur bonsoir un
avion malaisien détournés par des
pirates de l'air japonais explose en
plein vol non loin de singapour près de
cent victimes suite du sommet de tripoli
les mouvements palestiniens s'unissent
la réponse du gouvernement français à
l'assassinât d'un algérien en france il
ya deux jours le gouvernement fera
respecter l'ordre et la justice affirme
monsieur lionel stoléru sur antenne 2
l'invité de notre journal il s'agit ce
soir de monsieur michel d'ornano à
propos de la semaine sur le cadre de vie
qui débute demain à l'unesco à paris
voilà donc les titres et les grands
sujets de l'actualité de ce dimanche
sans oublier les rapports du tiercé nous
y reviendrons à la fin de cette édition
ce journal toutefois nous avons décidé
de l'ouvrir par un sujet qui à la fois
nous touchent de près et nous est
extrêmement étrange je veux parler pour
ce sujet des travailleurs immigrés ils
sont près de 5 millions à vivre en
france certains depuis vingt ou trente
ans quand c'était pas plus d'autres
depuis quelques semaines seulement
parmi ces étrangers il y à des groupes
plus ou moins important il ya les
immigrés d'origine nord-africaine ceux
qui viennent d'afrique noire ou d'asie
sans fin qui ont franchi pour une raison
ou pour une autre
à une époque où à une autre les pyrénées
les espagnols sont très nombreux à vivre
en france aujourd'hui il organisait à
paris la journée nationale de
l'immigration françois mitterrand et
felipe gonzalez de leader des
socialistes espagnols participent
d'ailleurs en ce moment même on les
attend en tout cas à une réunion à la
mutualité à paris une réunion qui était
l'occasion pour les immigrés espagnols
de faire le point sur leurs problèmes à
la commission
est-ce que c'est facile de vivre de
travailler en france je crois que le
début a été difficile
pourquoi la langue
le fait de ne pas avoir de diplôme
français mais une fois que j'ai eu un
diplôme français c'est à dire peu plus
facile on peut s'intégrer
ça demande un effort considérable
certainement pour un espagnol
mais
il faut s'approcher beaucoup de français
la tentation évidemment étant de rester
entre espagnols je ne pense pas qu'il ya
un reflux évidemment jeu là où je
travaille c'est peut-être pas tout à
fait représentatif de ce qui peut se
passer pour d'autres mais c'est
difficile
les enchères sont nés en espagne je
voudrais oui eh bien justement ces
immigrés s'ils ont des problèmes en
france ils connaissent aussi souvent des
problèmes lorsqu'ils tentent de rentrer
chez eux dans leur village ou bien dans
leur ville et finalement au bout d'un
certain nombre d'années
l'immigré ne sait plus très bien à quel
pays se raccrocher étrangers en france
il est aussi l'étranger entre guillemets
lorsqu'il rentre chez lui dans sa maison
dans sa province en france j'étais à
l'étranger
et si je suis un étranger et franchement
je ne sais pas c'est vraiment
désorientés
antonio garcia née à toulouse il y à 27
ans de parents espagnol émigré en france
citoyens espagnols jusqu'à l'âge de 18
ans a ensuite perdu sa nationalité en
refusant de faire son service militaire
sous les drapeaux espagnols du vivant de
franco aujourd'hui rentré en espagne il
a erré six mois de bureau en bureau pour
obtenir une carte de résidence et la
permission de travailler à madrid
le cas n'est pas unique il prouve
l'absurde d'une situation qui fait d'un
espagnol un travailleur immigré chez lui
que français je crois que je suis mieux
considérer que connaissent pagnol et
pour moi c'est positif seulement
c'est une situation fausse exactement
les migrations qui vide les villages
c'est depuis plus de vingt ans une plaie
sociale de l'espagne l'albert cas à 30
kilomètres de la frontière portugaise a
perdu le quart de ses habitants au cours
des dix dernières années ne reste ici
que les femmes les enfants et les vieux
car cette émigration là vers la france
essentiellement ne concerne que les
hommes en âge de travailler
les familles attendent le retour du père
de soi par an l'été et à noël
la vuvuzela
les pages sont partis pourquoi parce
qu'ici il y parle beaucoup de travail
pas problème à travailler ici elle est
parlée travail et quand les gens
reviennent aujourd'hui ils reviennent à
l'albert cas où ils vont dans d'autres
villes d'espagne se bat à machala à
l'apal palois ne restez pas l'alberta
lol
ceux qui rentrent définitivement ne se
reconnaissent plus dans le village
qu'ils ont quittée ils vont grossir les
banlieues ouvrières et allonger la queue
qui se forme chaque matin dans les
agences de l'emploi
l'espagne compte déjà près d'un million
de chômeurs et le retour définitif des
émigrés qui s'accélère avec la crise
économique
au rythme des mesures prises par les
anciens pays d'accueil prend l'espagne
de cours c'est un nouveau cheval de
bataille syndicale
le dernièrement l'année passée par
exemple plus de cent mille travailleurs
sont revenus les migrations vers
l'espagne eh bien nous nous retrouvons
aussi avec un manque de prévision un
manque de planification de la part des
gouvernements n'est ce pas du régime de
franco et même les deux derniers
gouvernements en y incluant celui qui
est en place il ya par exemple les
devises que ces travailleurs envoyés
n'aurait pas pu servir à créer un bien
sûr travail ce sont des millions de
millions de pc tu as qui sont venus
chaque année et qui comme vous le savez
vous devez le savoir les cet argent a
servi à équilibrer les déficits des
balances de paiements dans ce commercial
ce pays l'effort économique que les
émigrés ont fait pendant ces vingt
années a été énorme pour l'économie
espagnole
malheureusement cet argent en effet n'a
jamais été et ceux ci auraient dû être
dans le cadre d'une planification
justement non seulement d'une politique
de l'immigration mais en prévision d'une
politique du retour aurait dû être
investis dans des zones dont des
industries dans des secteurs d'activités
bien précis en vue de créer justement
dépenses de travail pour le jour venu
pouvoir réintégrer réinsérer dans la
société espagnole
tous ces travailleurs qui finalement
aurait été les producteurs de cet argent
les producteurs de ceux de ce tricheur
capital ceci n'a pas été fait
l'attitude de pays qui comme la france
ferment leurs portes à l'immigration
choc l'administration espagnole
elle oppose à paris fermeté diplomatique
et principes humains combat d'arrière
garde
avec la montée du chômage en europe on
sait bien à madrid de la voix de
l'immigration est coupée que le reflux
s'annonce et que l'on espère préparer
problème insoluble en affaires et que
dire lorsque l'on parle des travailleurs
immigrés qui viennent de pays plus
lointains et dont la couleur de la peau
n'est pas la même que la nôtre
essentiellement ces immigrés ce sont là
les algériens
avant-hier un homme père de famille a
été assassinée il gardait le local de
l'amicale des algériens en europe il a
été assassiné par un mystérieux commando
delta en représailles a dit ce commando
de l'enlèvement en mauritanie de
citoyens français
l'algérie a demandé des explications à
la france alger souhaite que des mesures
de protection particulières soient
prises pour protéger la communauté
algérienne à 13h monsieur lionel stone
rue était l'invité de notre journal le
secrétaire d'état chargé des
travailleurs immigrés a été très net
attention at il dit al escalade de la
violence au mans c'est le même piège que
le piège allemande la bande à baader
c'est à dire l'escaladé de la violence
sinon on commence à considérer que parce
qu'il ya des français qui sont d'une
manière inacceptable détenu par lé
polisario
il doit y avoir huit cent mille otages
algériens en france et que par
conséquent on accepte la prise d'otages
en réponse à une autre prise d'otages
nous entrons dans un processus
inacceptable qui est un piège tendu au
gouvernement et le gouvernement doit
garder en cette matière
la seule conduite qui peut être celle du
great democratic faire respecter l'ordre
et la justice
je voudrais dire aux français qu' il ne
faut pas tomber dans le piège qui
consiste à dire que chacun va commencer
à se rendre justice lui même n'est ce
pas il ya comme ça des les milices
civiles qui essayent de garantir l'ordre
dans tel ou tel endroit des groupes qui
estime qu' ils vont rendre la justice
eux mêmes non quand chacun commence à
vouloir rendre la justice ni même on
quitte la démocratie et on entre dans le
fascisme oui s'il vous plaît monsieur le
ministre à la politique avec les
différents sondages d'opinion publiées
dans les journaux ou bien dans les
hebdomadaires et qui seront en vente
demain excusez moi mais chez empreinte
de téléphone je n'arrive pas à me
remettre très exactement l'endroit où il
devrait être
voilà la politique donc avec les
sondages d'opinion un sondage qui est
très intéressant c'est celui réalisé par
l'ifop pour notre confrère le point un
sondage de l copains à double détente si
je puis dire puisqu'il porte pour le
premier tour sur le nombre des voix et
pour le second tour sur le nombre des
sièges que pour être éventuellement
obtenir les différents partis politiques
aux prochaines élections we are soul et
rapidement je vous rappelle les chiffres
est essentiel donc au premier tour
l'opposition l'emportent en nombre de
voix avec un pourcentage de 51 % contre
45 % à la majorité au deuxième tour par
contre c'est la majorité qui n'emporte
en nombre de sièges
242 sièges contre 231 à l'opposition de
gauche
dans l'hypothèse où il y aurait un seul
candidat de la gauche mais sa victoire
serait plus net s'il y avait deux
candidats de la gauche qui s'oppose 2
174 sièges pour la majorité donc contre
199 à l'opposition cette apparente
contradiction s'explique par le fait que
les reports de voix au deuxième tour à
gauche s'effectue de plus en plus mal en
gros selon les situations il ignorait
que de 42 à 45 % de l'électorat de
gauche qu'ils voteraient pour un
candidat communiste au deuxième tour 30%
se réfugier dans l'abstention
je suppose que les partis politiques
français qu'ils soient de droite ou de
gauche vont tirer des conclusions de ce
sondage
oui elle a raison pour eux c'est une
bonne issue nicole est sûre alors du
côté des du côté de la majorité et on
adopte et surtout que le rpr demeurait
nettement en tête avec 24% alors la
situation risque d'être la suivante
et cette majorité qui il faut bien le
dire ne satisfaisait pas pleinement le
président de la république et ne
correspondait pas pleinement à ses voeux
et risquent d'être reconduite à peu près
avec le rapport de force existant
actuellement
c'est à dire que le rpr de jacques
chirac a des chances de rester
la majorité de la majorité alors que se
passera-t-il
jusqu'où pourra-t-il aller
éventuellement dans les exigences
jusqu'où le prêt dans la république
pourrait qu'il allait lui éventuellement
dans des compromis il y a là un problème
assez délicat qui peut se poser après
l'élection
du côté de l'opposition et bien tout se
passe comme si la rupture des
négociations à gauche avait affaibli un
peu le ps avait renforcé un peu le pc et
puis surtout avait cassé la dynamique
et de l'union de lyon de l'union de la
gauche les sondages peut-il amener un
changement comportement des partenaires
par exemple de voir le ps sortir de son
attitude un peu défensive ou bien
peut-on voir le pc ne plus se satisfaire
seulement de s'être renforcée au risque
de laisser passer la majorité aux
prochaines élections
oui noël quoi pas les chiffres en tout
cas nous prouve une chose je crois ce
soir c'est que la lutte politique en
france sera très très serré il ne serait
pas d'ici avant le dernier jour c'est à
dire jusqu'au 12 mars 1978 à minuit
pratiquants ou alors finalement la
question principale qu'on peut se poser
pour après les élections c'est si ça ne
sera pas très difficile de gouverner un
pays qui demeure très divisé et puis ce
fait et une impression personnelle
impayés qui paraît à la lumière de ces
sondages un peu désenchanté il ya eu au
cours de la cinquième république
un courant gaulliste très fort qui s'est
prolongée et puis il y a eu un courant
que la gauche a sucré en signifiant et
ce courant brusquement s'est brisé
maintenant la majorité ne paraît pas
tout à fait être en mesure de bénéficier
de cette rupture et en caricaturant un
peu ce sondage on a un peu l'impression
que les français vont voté contre la
majorité au premier tour contre
l'opposition au second tour vous
rappeler une formule célèbre au premier
tour on choisit au deuxième tour on
élimine et bien jouer un peu sur les
mots on a l'impression qu'au deuxième
tour
les français vont éliminer la gauche
qu'elle aura choisi au premier tour
j'adore et là vous êtes venus ce soir
nous parler de cette première rencontre
européenne sur le cadre de vie mais vous
êtes aussi et surtout un homme politique
ce que vous pensez vu de ce sondage
finalement que le gouvernement puisse
sortir en 1978 avec une majorité qui
finalement aura peut-être la majorité
des sièges mais pas la majorité des voix
est ce que ce gouvernement pourra
gouverner pour écouter d'abord on ne
parle pas du gouvernement futur au vu
d'un sondage qui vient de se passer en
ce moment mais croit quand vous parlez
de ce sondage ce sujet protestation
d'âge qui à mon avis est significatif au
plan national bien sûr
on voit que le scrutin pour le moment
apparaît comme serré et je crois que
nous nous devons et pouvons gagner le
prochain combat électoral bien ce qui
concerne la répartition à travers la
majorité à travers les différentes
composantes qui soutiennent le
gouvernement
alors je crois qu'il est surprenant de
voir un institut sérieux l ifop est un
institut très sérieux prendre des bases
qui sont aussi peu significative et est
aussi fragile que vous voyez ça a été
fait ces sondages si je les ai bien lui
ont été réalisés dans des
circonscriptions où il y a plus de
candidats rpr que deux candidats du
parti républicain de l'aide à peu près
le double en attendant sur la santé
alors alors on pose la question alors
pour qui voter vous pour qui vous voulez
vous que quelqu'un qui veut soutenir le
gouvernement vote si ce n'est pour le
seul candidat c'est un fps tout à fait
normal mais il n'y a pas un choix qui
est donnée là à tout le monde
entre plusieurs mouvements je vous
dirais que c'est un petit peu ça me fait
penser à la la vieille histoire de la
maîtresse de maison qui offre le café à
ses invités qui leur dit un sucre ou pas
du tout on ne saura jamais qui a repris
le dessus en fin de même 13 % pour le
parti du président de la moitié 6,6 à la
moitié de candidats ça se comprend parce
que c'est qu'en attendant on ne pourra
pas pour le moment on ne peut procéder à
des sondages qu'au niveau national
ceux là ont une signification des
intentions de vote pour tel ou tel parti
alors il ya des sondages sont faits là
dessus on les voit on ne pourra procéder
au sondage entre les candidats que je
dirai au dernier moment et quand tous
les candidats seront connus sinon
nécessairement ceux qui sont sortants
sont ceux qui à l'heure actuelle pas
reste à voir le plus est ministre quand
même en dépassant dans les conditions de
ce sondage lui-même tous les sondages
montrent que la france on est toujours à
peu près à 50 % 50 % dans la crise
économique il traverse on n'est pas
encore sorti est il possible d'agir et
de gouverner il sans avoir ce qu'on
appelait un large consensus
j'écoute et je crois que la première des
choses qui va compter pour le moment ça
sera la victoire des partis qui
soutiennent le gouvernement
c'est pour ça que nous combattons c'est
ça ce qui m'importe
parce que nous savons très bien que sans
cela on ne pourrait pas gouverner or je
vous demande d'observer qu'à l'heure
actuelle nous gouvernons nous avons une
situation qui est celle que vous
décrivez est en ce moment il ya un
gouvernement qui est cohérent des
ministres qui sont issus de différents
en partie de toutes les formations qui
soutiennent le gouvernement vous
n'oubliez pas de dissension ce
gouvernement gouverne il prend des
décisions ces décisions sont appliquées
et j'ai le sentiment que les français
ont le sentiment d'être gouverné l'île
ce consensus vous paraît satisfaisant à
l'intérieur même de la maîtrise et la
nature en ce moment c'est comme ça par
conséquent il faut prendre les choses
comme elles sont donc après les
élections nous verrons ce que sont le
résultat des élections mais pour le
moment il est démontré qu'un
gouvernement comme celui ci peut
gouverner et gouvernent
g lausanne 11 n'oublions pas tout même
que vous êtes ministre de la qualité de
la vie de l'environnement alors demain
vous allez prononcer le discours
d'ouverture disons du premier de l'idée
première rencontre européenne du cadre
de vie s'agit d'un symposium d'une
réunion d'une conférence de puces ou est
ce que vous attendez quelque chose de
très concret de cette réunion il s'agit
de quelque chose je crois tout à fait
différent
c'est une initiative du président de la
république du hac ça n'étonnera personne
le président de la république avait déjà
pris des initiatives de ce genre
du temps où il était ministre de
l'économie et des finances vous savez
combien il est préoccupé par le cadre de
vie l'environnement des français c'est
lui qui a arrêté à paris les tours les
voies express tout ça alors là nous
allons réunir à partir de demain et pour
trois jours un millier de personnes
en dépassant les structures des
gouvernements on a appelé des gens qui
viennent de tous les pays d'europe
occidentale et qui sont des gens qui ont
des responsabilités dans le la vie
quotidienne le cadre de vie des français
il peut y avoir d'aidé des hommes de
gouvernement des architectes des
urbanistes des assistantes sociales des
responsables de quartiers et on a
demandé à tous ces gens là n'ont pas de
venir parler mais de venir montrer ce
qu'ils ont fait
chacun dans leur pays cette
préoccupation du cadre de vie et les
européennes on voit bien que maintenant
les français et je dirais les européens
qui ont dépassé
le moment du besoin matériel le plus
urgent qu'ils veulent maintenant une
qualité qui soit différente de celle
qu'ils avaient rapidement dans ce
domaine la france rassure tout à
apprendre pendant ces trois jours on
pourrait donner des conseils aux heureux
de l'apprendre en france pourra et
apprendre et donné beaucoup de conseils
il s'agira de voir comment on fait nos
centres de deux villes
comment on aménage l'autre temps comment
on aménage aussi la vie sociale à
travers les villes et à travers les
campagnes c'est tout ça qu'on va parler
en montrant ce qu'on a fait merci un
avion malaisien s'est écrasé cet après
midi vont loin de singapour à son bord
se trouvait 93 passagers et cinq membres
d'équipage
il n'y aurait pas de survivants selon
les informations que nous avons nous
connaissons actuellement
l'accident se serait produit alors que
l'appareil était détourné par un
commando de pirates de l'air ce commando
appartiendrait à l'armée rouge japonaise
c'est tout ce que l'on sait pour
l'instant au proche orient la détente
est réel désormais entre israël et
l'egypte un signe ne trompe pas alors
que depuis trente ans les communications
téléphoniques étaient interrompues entre
jérusalem et le caire elles ont été
rétablies pour tout le monde ce matin
égyptiens et israéliens peuvent donc
maintenant dialogue pendant ce temps le
sommet arabe de tripoli continue de
suspension de séance en suspension de
séance à 20 heures les délégués devaient
se retrouver un seul élément nouveau les
différents mouvements palestiniens ont
décidé de se réunir sous une même
bannière
aboya lieutenant de yasser arafat au
centre avec à sa droite georges habache
à sa gauche
nayef hawatmeh la noyade annonce qu'une
plateforme politique est un terreau
prestine yens a été adoptée cette plate
forme et c'est là la surprise scelle la
réconciliation entre les différentes
organisations de libération de la
palestine elle comprend six points elle
s'oppose formellement à tout conférence
y compris celles de genève à la fin la
conférence de presse à bois yade prend
les mains dabbashi des watts mais il ya
longtemps et palestiniens ne s'était pas
montré aussi une cette nouvelle
stratégie palestinienne au fond le seul
résultat concret pour l'instant que
kadhafi boumédiène ont réussi à obtenir
elle doit être soumise en fin de soirée
aux chefs des délégations mais il n'est
pas sûr du tout cas fait ça va ça le
président syrien accepte jusqu'à présent
le syrien s'est tenue en retrait ait
réussi à
évitez au cours du sommet tripoli
d'engager formellement son pays dans le
camp des arabes du refus yasser arafat
quant à lui franchi pas la plateforme dr
aujourd'hui partout les palestiniens
signifient une position beaucoup plus
dures d'europe et par rapport aux
positions officielles
l'armée britannique intervient aux
bermudes 150 soldats ont été envoyés
d'urgence d'angleterre par avion pour
ramener le calme dans l'archipel les
troubles aux bermudes ont éclaté jeudi
soir après l'exécution de deux noirs qui
avait été condamné par un tribunal pour
meurtre des scènes d'une extrême
violence se déroule depuis 48 heures à
wellington capitale administrative des
îles permet tout a commencé lorsque il y
a deux jours deux hommes zones noires
condamné pour plusieurs meurtres dont
celui en 1973 du gouverneur de l'île ont
été pendus selon la loi britannique en
vigueur dans ces territoires
mais en grande bretagne la peine de mort
est abolie alors la population noire de
lille des jeunes pour la plupart ont
commencé une série de manifestations qui
ont débouché sur les scènes de violence
que vous voyez plusieurs magasins
incendiés une école un supermarché des
voitures détruites et des forces de
police
insuffisante pour faire face à l'ennemi
il n'en fallait pas plus pour le
gouverneur de l'île qu'il fasse appel à
l'armée britannique 150 hommes du
régiment royal de fusiller sont arrivées
ce soir dans l'île et puis et je leur ai
terminé avec les informations de
l'étranger l'afrique a depuis ce matin à
l'instar du japon et de la perse un
empereur les cérémonie du couronnement
de bokassa 1er se sont déroulés à bangui
ce matin nous vous entre montreront les
images mercredi soir dans quelques jours
plusieurs milliers de jeunes français
vont partir pour accomplir leurs
obligations militaires chaque année 300
mille jeunes français âgés de 18 à 20
ans sont ainsi appelés sous les drapeaux
l'armée de terre à elle seule en
recrutant environ 230 milles bien
souvent son service militaire terminée
la plaie rentrer chez lui avec
l'impression d'avoir perdu 12 mois de 16
pour remédier à ce malaise
l'armée a donc mis au point un nouveau
style d'instruction militaire il s'agit
d'intéresser les appeler et de les
motiver en leur faisant faire une
intense participation à leurs propres
instructions cette nouvelle pédagogie
est en cours d'expérimentation dans six
unités de l'armée de terre françois
cornet a voulu juger sur pièce au 153e
régiment d'infanterie à régime enquête à
mutzig dans le bas rhin
l'homme du contingent selon l'état major
de l'armée de terre doit être en 1977
opérationnel il ne doit plus passer son
temps à balayer la cour du quartier pour
tourner en rangs serrés dans son
casernement
il a un an pour apprendre un métier
celui de soldats qu'ils soient
mécanicien ou radio tireur pilotes de
chars au grenadier voltigeur la plaie ne
doit plus être un individu passe ip
isolé mais un exécutant responsable il
lui faut pour cela passer tout d'abord
par l'apprentissage du matériel et des 1
cet apprentissage consiste à apprendre
des gestes à savoir utiliser du matériel
ou à connaître certains éléments
tactiques de l'émission l'armement est
de plus en plus sophistiqués savoir
démonter remonter au se servir d'un
pistolet mitrailleur ou d'un lance
roquettes anti char est plus compliquée
que d'apprendre à saluer ou marcher au
pas le but de cette nouvelle pédagogie
militaire d'instruction et d'intéresser
le plus possible les appeler aux
missions de l'armée de terre le jeune
actuelle a besoin de savoir ce qu'il
fait de participer de savoir pourquoi il
doit apprendre telle ou telle chose
de la même façon il veut être concerné
par tout ce qu'il fait tous les jours à
l'instruction dans la vie d'un corps de
troupe l'armée après l'entreprise a
découvert les vertus de la motivation du
personnel
elle demande aujourd'hui aux contingents
de participer plutôt que de subir avant
chaque mission sur le terrain la section
se transforme en petit état major chacun
peut donner son avis sur la façon de
tendre une embuscade ou réduire une
résistance avez vous l'impression que
quelque chose a changé avec cette
nouvelle pédagogie militaires dans le
civil je suis mineur de fond je descends
au fond je tape dans le charbon
on ne s'intéresse pas au courant donne
pas ou que mon avis mais depuis que je
suis ici je participe aux discussions
aux décisions de ma section je ne pense
pas que je perds mon temps
longtemps faute de moyens l'infanterie
restée clouée dans ces cases ernement la
revalorisation de l'armée classique
imposé à ces unités un nouveau rythme
d'instruction pour être opérationnel
après des deux phases de formation
militaire et d'apprentissage on juge les
appeler sur le terrain
la troisième phase c'est la rigueur
opérationnel c'est le rendez vous que
fixent le capitaine à son chef de
section à d'affection pour savoir si
tout le monde est en mesure d'accomplir
cette mission
c'est le rendez vous sur l'objectif à ce
moment là chacun reprend sa place dans
la chaîne de commandement
on exécute et la discussion bien sûr
n'est plus admises puisque il faut
accomplir des missions à un rythme
intense ceci pendant deux jours des
missions de plus en plus complexes qui
sont fixées par le commandant du monde
bien sûr il y a tout de même un moment
où il faut se mettre au garde à vous
dans l'armée mais les temps ont changé
l'ami bidasse même s'il n'a pas de
galles on a le droit aujourd'hui d'avoir
des idées psychologie et dynamique de
groupe
l'armée de terre a recours en 1977 aux
sciences humaines pour tenter de
l'intéressé l'expérience sera élargie en
1960 18 mai la décision de l'étendre à
toute l'armée de terre ne sera prise que
l'été prochain
déjà qu est-ce qui danse au mur
montpellier angers saint maixent les
écoles forment les premières promotions
d'officiers et de sous-officiers à
appliquer cette nouvelle pédagogie dans
les unités
j'avais un tir c'est aujourd'hui un
tiercé qui se courait dans la 6e course
à auteuil ce tiercé a été remporté par
château gaillard le 601 suivi de marc
webb le 613 et de marie teva le 612 la
combinaison gagnante dont place le 13 et
le 12 les rapports 5669 francs 50 pour 5
francs dans l'ordre et 765 150 jours
cinq francs mais dans un ordre différent
avant de nous quitter je voudrais vous
montrer un ange à un peu spécial une
planche à quatre roues une voix
l'intermédiaire donc entre le char à
voile le skateboard et le windsurf un
engin destiné à être utilisé sur les
plages les routes les aérodromes les
terrains de football un peu partout donc
si le terrain est à l'engin rapide
attention aux chutes et peut atteindre
80 km heure environ à la cause l'est et
lé l'essayer sur la plage d'hendaye
c'est donc lui qui mettra fin avec ses
images à ce journal je souhaite de
passer une très bonne soirée
et
prenons le cas
notre passage
ce traité
mais
les
tél
de l'année
dans la paix